[Music]
so you're in need of money but you've
run out of legal ways to make it making
money legally is hard time consuming you
actually have to sell something people
want and you have to fulfill on it we
need something easier a product that is
so tempting that it sells itself but
when the sucker buys poof you just pull
the rug from under them and disappear
with their money back in the wolf of
wall street days you would just shove
penny socks down people's throats and
take a giant commission a few years back
it might have been selling a stock
trading box or a forex trading bots that
supposedly makes you money while you
sleep but today we have something even
better even more tempting a crypto
trading box
imagination
why because if you think about it it is
the perfect pitch imagine instead of you
tirelessly staring at your computer 24
hours a day seven days a week trying to
trade crypto you had a computer do that
for you what if instead of trying to buy
low and sell high and inevitably failing
at it you could have a computer
systematically buy at every dip and
still at every peak for you something
like this would allow you to take all
your emotions out of trading think about
the tens of thousands or even millions
of dollars you can make on autopilot
while you sleep all thanks to your
trusty crypto trading bot that does all
the work for you and what if i told you
you could get all of this for just a
teeny tiny fee all you have to do is
sign up for a platform transfer some
crypto to start trading and watch your
money double trip or even quadruple
every few days thanks to our
revolutionary trading algorithm this is
a great pitch that builds off of the
proven psychology of stock trading bots
and forex trading bots that has been
fooling suckers for years and it's why a
countless number of people around the
world have fallen from the exact same
pitch i just gave you when in reality
most enemy most crypto trading bots are
complete scams but how do you
successfully pull off this heist how do
you go about getting the most suckers to
part ways with their money well my name
is jake tran i make documentaries on
money power war and crime with my team
subscribe for more and this is your
guide to becoming a crypto trading bot
scammer
[Music]
a group of really smart people looked at
how sketchy and disgusting this industry
of crypto trading bots was and realized
that a legit crypto trading bot tool
would actually be really useful for
people who trade crypto so they created
pi next the only u.s regulated crypto
exchange that provides free built-in
trading bots with licenses to operate in
36 states and counting and they're
registered as a money services business
with the us's financial crisis
enforcement network so they're very
above board and their today's video
sponsor i've met the founder and the
team in person they're great and the
product itself is actually legit you can
set up your own custom bots based on
your parameters deploy them to start
training automatically with your money
see the trades come in and withdraw your
money i've actually set up what's called
their grid trading bot 11 days ago give
it one thousand dollars to trade with
and i'm already up three percent on it
nothing crazy but also pretty good for
just 11 days and something like this is
especially useful during very sideways
markets like what we're experiencing
right now and the great thing is pinex
doesn't over promise and tell you that
you're going to be a millionaire
overnights unlike what most crypto
trading bots promise it is just a great
tool to add to your investing arsenal
and for a limited time pioneers is
giving you guys anywhere from twenty to
five hundred dollars in free crypto just
for signing up and giving it a try with
the link below more about them at the
end of the video now back to the dark
side of crypto training bots
[Music]
[Music]
1998's long-term capital management or
ltcm was the biggest wall street hedge
fund in the 90s ltcm lewd wall street
with a bunch of brand new flashy
mathematical models that they were using
to beat the markets it was new it was
sexy and soon they were able to fool
pretty much every major financial
institution on wall street into giving
them billions no one looked at these
math formulas no one did any due
diligence to make sure they actually
worked everyone just saw how much money
ltcm was making and they won it in and
these weren't dum-dums giving them money
by the way these were prestigious
organizations like stanford harvard that
were begging to get in on the action in
the end ltcm gambled the money away
crashed almost took the entire financial
system down with them and then got a
government bailout the whole uh economic
system was going to collapse if the
bailout didn't happen these guys in a
room took 4.8 billion got knucklehead
over here to give them 125 and then got
these knuckleheads to sell them
positions and all of a sudden 4.8
billion equaled 1.4 trillion
and
what's the lesson from this is that if
long-term capital management was able to
fool really really smart and rich people
into giving them money thanks to their
trading algorithm that made them look
like they knew what they were doing
imagine how many people you could fool
with that same strategy for your crypto
trading bot scheme the first thing you
need to learn is what exactly a crypto
trading bot is basically it's an
automated trading algorithm you give it
a set of rules to follow buy when this
happens sell when this happens and it
does it on your behalf and these are a
legit thing by the way in fact wall
street has been using trading bots for
years
but again we're not actually gonna do
any of that heavy lifting building a bot
from scratch we're simply just gonna
google some crypto trading strategies
that sound super complex mathematical
and academic just like that hedge fund
ltcm did and then we're gonna use all
that jargon to make it sound like we've
uncovered a brand new super complex
trading algorithm that's beating the
crypto market every single day just like
the hedge fund ltcm did
that we just doubled our money in the
last month thanks to this new algorithm
maybe sprinkle some mathematical
equations into your presentation and
promo videos and as long as you sound
absolutely certain that you know what
you're doing and that you're making a
ton of money with it already just like
we saw earlier no one is gonna bat an
eye no one's gonna look into it to see
if you're telling the truth people are
just gonna go whoo this is a little over
my head so just take my money already if
you can get that emotional response out
of people you are golden once you've
perfected your pitch all you gotta do is
make a legit looking investment platform
also known as a website and boom you're
good to go
[Music]
now that you have your pitch now it's
time for the easy parts faking your
trades the great thing about crypto
culture compared to say stocks or
traditional investing is that being
anonymous isn't just okay it is the norm
before if you want to scam someone out
of thousands of dollars you would have
to spend hours creating a fake persona
then you use that fake name and
backstory to get people to trust you
before you rob them blind but in crypto
decentralization and anonymity is
everything think about the founder of
bitcoin he is anonymous yes the man that
started all of crypto satoshi nakamoto
is himself anonymous anonymity is baked
into the very fabric of this culture so
like satoshi make it seem like you being
anonymous is your choice like your bot
is just so revolutionary you're afraid
people will try to take it from you if
they knew who you were by doing that
you're not only making it harder for
people to find you once you disappear
with their money but you're adding
intrigue to your whole pitch you're
making it sound more enticing one of the
only ways to check of a crypto trading
bot is legit is to compare the
transactions the bot makes to the public
blockchain ledger every trade the bot
says it makes should be on the
blockchain but if no one knows who you
are there's no way they can tie the lack
of transactions on the blockchain to you
one of the biggest crypto trading boss
games of this decade went by the name of
bitconnect
the founders and managers of the company
actually managed to stay anonymous the
entire time and yet people still handed
more than 2 billion over to them
now your job is ridiculously easy you
literally just say on your website that
your bot is bringing in whatever 10 50
100 returns every month you literally
just make up a number and no one is
gonna be able to prove you wrong
sure some people are too smart to fall
for the guaranteed returns trick but
remember you're not targeting
experienced crypto people you're
targeting the newbies the middle aged
people that keep hearing about crypto
but don't know how to get started those
are your victims
and once you've promised record-breaking
returns to people who don't know any
better it's time for your next move
so you've created your trading bot you
set up your trading platform also known
as a website and you've set up a wallet
that your victims will deposit their
money into to be traded with when you're
actually just going to launder that
money into your own pockets and now it's
time for the most important step
promotion you need to get as many
eyeballs onto your revolutionary trading
bot as possible so you pay social media
influencers to market your bots this
part is pretty simple you get these
influencers to believe your bot is real
by paying them returns they got from
using your bot so they're super super
sold in it you give them a percentage of
any money their followers give you and
they'll sell your bot for you to their
followers with ease that way you get
super legit influencers to peddle your
scheme and make it look real but that's
not all don't stop with influencers to
make your bot look even more real create
a youtube account for your platform and
start posting videos of walkthroughs and
how much money your investors are making
you can then create more fake youtube
accounts to comment on your own videos
about how your bot changed their lives
then tell people that they don't need to
invest much that they just need one
small deposit to get started even if
they invest just 500
they could be making thousands within a
month to most people 500 is a lot but
not so much that they start overthinking
things once you've blasted every social
media site in existence you've paid
influencers to promote your bots and you
sign up as many suckers as possible now
it is time to step it up a notch
[Music]
the reason why big connect became so
successful and viral was because they
didn't just stop at promoting a
revolutionary trading bot but they
turned it into a ponzi scheme now that
you have some money in the bank it's
time to start letting some of your early
victims withdraw some of their earnings
now this may seem like a waste of money
on your part and that you should just
keep the money and walk away but you are
missing the bigger picture here think of
it as an investment by letting some of
your early victims cash out you turn
your victims into your greatest sales
people think about it when people make a
great investment and they make a ton of
money they won't stop bragging about how
smart they are to their friends and
family once their friends and family
hear about just how much money your bot
made your victim they'll want in too
this will create a viral effect bringing
in customers that you would have never
reached before and making you way more
money and when you decide to stop and
finally pull the rug is up to you but
the important thing here is to not get
too greedy because although bitconnect
made a ton of money they attracted so
much attention they created so many
victims that when everything finally
came crashing down there were a lot of
angry people enough angry people to
justify an investigation that eventually
led to the arrest of two of the main
founders years later even though they
tried staying anonymous
so don't go past the mark you aimed for
in victory learn when to stop or else
you will end up in ruin make enough
money for you to live a comfortable life
but not enough to justify a worldwide
manhunt to bring you to justice and when
you decide to stop simply delete
everything your website your social
media accounts launder the crypto you
made and disappear into thin air
[Music]
what sucks about all this is that a real
legit trading bot is still a very
powerful tool to have in your arsenal
when it comes to investing in crypto and
a group of really smart people felt the
same way so they looked at how sketchy
and disgusting this industry of crypto
training bots was and decided to make a
change so they created pi next the only
u.s regulated crypto exchange that
provides free built-in trading bots with
licenses to operate in 36 states and
counting what's great about pinex is
that they don't overhype their products
they don't promise some magical bot that
will make you a millionaire overnight
they don't promise insane returns of 40
a month guaranteed or whatever they just
offer 11 built-in trading bots that you
can customize to your heart's content
that do run 24 7 that do take the
emotions of trading that also happen to
be great for sideways markets like what
we're in today pie next is great
liquidity they're well funded and
they're registered as a money services
business with the us's financial crimes
enforcement network i've actually
deployed a bot myself just 11 days ago
on pinex gave it a thousand dollars to
trade with and i'm already up three
percent on it nothing crazy but still
pretty good for just 11 days the type of
trading algorithm i used is called the
grid trading bots and it's actually
pretty simple basically you overlay a
grid on top of bitcoin for example and
whenever bitcoin crosses below each of
those lines it will buy a little buying
the dip and whenever it crosses above
one of those lines it will sell a little
selling at the tops so it's basically an
automated way to buy low sell high
without you having to sit in front of
your computer screen waiting for the
price to move yourself and what's great
is that since it sells as the price is
going up you lock in profits before the
price goes back down which is why it
works in a sideways market and all it
takes is a 0.05 fee and for a limited
time pi next is giving you guys up to 30
in free crypto just for signing up and
giving it a try with the link below
here's how it works once you sign up for
pi next with the link below you'll then
have to deposit some money into your
account to start trading and there's a
few ways you can do this you can deposit
usdt also known as tether into your
account on this page under wallet and
deposits but by far the easiest way is
via your debit card where you can
deposit a max of a thousand dollars
now that i have some money deposited
into my account i'll head over to the
trade tab on the top left and here you
can choose whichever crypto you want to
set up a trading bot for out of all
these different options and then right
below it you have all the different
trading algorithms you can choose from
there's a lot of them but i only like to
stick to the grid trading algorithm that
we explained earlier so to create one
i'm going to go ahead and click on
create and then i have two options i can
use their ai strategy to automatically
set the parameters for me but i should
probably understand what's happening and
set things manually so i'm going to go
with manual and the first setting i'm
going to set is the lower and upper
price in my case i'm going to set the
lower limit to 15 000 and the upper two
hundred fifty thousand dollars what this
means is that the bot will only trade
when bitcoin is within this range of
fifteen thousand to a hundred fifty
thousand dollars if bitcoin goes outside
of that range this bot will shut down
automatically then i'm gonna set the
number of grids and i'm going to try to
set this to the highest number possible
in this case 200 grid lines then i'll
choose how much money i want to put into
the spot using the slider i'll slide it
to 100 and then i'll click creates it
will give me a pop-up recommending me
use micro bitcoin but for now i'll just
stick with bitcoin and click ok this is
just the final confirmation page showing
all the parameters i chose and then i'll
click continue and that's it now the bot
is up and running i can release the
profits from my bot whenever i want here
and i can withdraw money from pi next
whenever i want here as you can see it's
pretty easy to use so if any of this
looks interesting to you for a limited
time pinex is giving you guys 30 free
crypto just for signing up and giving it
a try with the link below they're a big
supporter of the channel they're one of
the only legit players in this market
industry and it's just a great product
so pause the video and claim up to 30
free crypto by signing up for pi next
with the link below thanks to pinex for
sponsoring this video
you